[Music]
first of all let me jump right on in um
thank you for coming by the collider
outdoor whatever we're gonna call this
thing but secondly I absolutely loved
loved the first two episodes of your
show yeah no no everyone's right like
you know when you keep on hearing that
buzz like it's gonna be like it's really
good but then you seem you're like oh no
it's better than the buzz that's your
show I absolutely loved it um so for all
of you guys what is it like reading
these scripts for the first time because
it's like nothing I've seen on any movie
or any TV yeah we quite often discuss
the fact that every time we get a new
script there is something completely
perverse and shocking that absolutely
flaws us every single time without
without fail and then we first it's late
I've got a couple leave we get to do
this and then it's secondly it's like
how the hell are we gonna do this this
is insane
so yeah this the show's offering an
audience something that they just won't
see anywhere else that's for sure
yeah for me it's like you know usually
scripts are kind of like homework cuz
you got to study and learn your lines
and it's completely the opposite on this
show like you look forward to the next
script like you're dying to find out
what happens to this character or that
character and and you're always looking
for that one moment that's gonna shock
the hell out of you every script has at
least one I mean when I first read the
script for the pilot I I wasn't even
aware that it was based off a comic book
I was just like someone took the real
the real world as it is now and they
added superheroes into it and and all of
the implications that that implies you
know and all the collateral damage yeah
every episode has a shocking moment but
I just think on top of that our scripts
have really human moments as well and
that's what I think makes the show so
special I've got to say our prosthetics
department has done a lovely job of
doing all the wounds and the cuts and
the blood so yeah it's a gray shirt I
want to jump also like you guys already
have been blessed by a second season
which is before before it even premieres
they're like yeah this is what we call
good do you know what I mean because
they haven't even looked at the ratings
and said we have a winner you know when
did you find out you were getting a
second season and
what is it like to have that before it
even premieres we found out a few months
ago and we were actually a couple of
episodes into shooting it and for us
it's just firstly it's wonderful to have
a vote of confidence from Amazon and
secondly we're delighted that the fans
that devote their time and energy and
invest in this show are going to be
rewarded and they're gonna get to see
more so it's a good thing all around now
it's exciting I mean I think season 2 I
think season 1 is amazing I think season
2 is shaping up to be even better so I'm
just really excited for people to see it
so I'm actually in the dark I don't know
how you haven't started filming season 2
already a couple of episodes Oh for real
yeah oh I had no idea we all came from
Toronto so yeah yeah okay how it kept a
secret I don't know because of Toronto
you were like a level one Instagram
detective you'd be like okay Anthony has
bleach blonde hair karl has a beard
they're all in Toronto they're going
again well that explains Anthony's over
there with that hair and I'm like oh
must be for a role but I don't think I
had no idea exactly I had no idea so
wait so Wow is it gonna be eight
episodes the second season eight
episodes that's correct
Wow okay so for each of you guys what's
a day from season one that will not
spoil the show that you will always
remember forever okay I there's a damn
season one that will go down in infamy
for me I was a scene with hailey Joe
Osmond in a in a bathroom and I was
gonna leave it there thank you when we
first find the female she's all caged up
and you know filming this scene where
she's getting out of the cage you'll see
it on Friday is it it's one of my
favorite days of filming from last year
yeah I would say mine was a episode
three when my character first gets
introduced you know I came in a little
after these guys had already gotten
their feet wet and it's been a long time
that I've worked on the
project that I felt like you know a kids
first day in school and you're nervous
and you got butterflies and you hope
that your performance is on par with
everyone else's and and you know I'll
never forget that moment it's it's good
that after so many years and working on
so many projects I still feel that way
and this project made me feel that way
thing about it was I think when the
character of Karen if the female came on
it did something it was very strong for
me as Frenchie you know the whole thing
changed for me like and I could play
with it and I had I think that's
something I'll remember forever was a
scene that happened on my second day on
set I don't want to give it away too
much it's in some trailers but basically
something very traumatic happens to my
character and it was just such a surreal
day and just like hey welcome to the
show man this is what we got in store
for you
I know exactly what your talk yeah you
dude I'm not gonna reveal it of course
but it was a holy [ __ ] moment when I was
watching it yeah I didn't watch the
marketing on purpose so when that
happened my jaw was on the ground -
you've never seen anything like that you
never have and that was just like I
don't know I've never I just I can't
talk about I know sorry I don't want to
spoil for everybody that's amazing you
just avoided the trailers and you were
just that's the best way to do it
no no I'm a professional there you go so
real quick is that like the second group
I got to bring in who ruins the most who
ruins the most takes and why I think
it's a question actually pretty much all
on point sure who's giving you five
dollars to say that listen III do want
to say this I love the fact that the
minute we step on on on set we kind of
know where the other person is gonna go
it's like a choreographed dance and we
do what our characters would do and
except for one person who always ends up
in front of my face and steals all my
clothes
I'm not gonna say who that person is
right exactly
nah man but a lot further in their hates
friendship you need completion yeah but
nowhere if I mean it all of us I mean
it's rarely happens that everybody comes
on set and they're like so mindset it on
their characters and we will love our
characters only love the story so every
day it's like right on it's like the
Michael Jordan Bulls man yeah especially
now in season two I feel like we all
just got even closer and we're hopeful
like even us in the soups we're just all
a big happy family at this point
sure my last thing real fast who always
gets it in one take Karl Karl he good
I'm not gonna agree with you but not not
always but I yeah gets us home early
yeah I really mean it I could ask you a
million other questions when I see the
rest of the show I hope I can talk to
you guys again thank you so much for
coming by thank you